Darf ich wieder anfangen?
Müssen Sie nicht.
Ich bin zuständig Assenzarzt.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Bevor ich zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden komme, muss ich noch ein paar Fragen zu
Ihren persönlichen Daten stellen.
Falls etwas unklar ist, unterbrechen Sie bitte nicht.
Und wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Friedhelm Behring.
Könnten Sie Name und Nachname langsam und deutlich beschreiben?
Friedhelm schreibt sich F-R-I-E-D.
Friedhelm, F-R-I-E-D-H-E-L-M.
Friedhelm ist der Vorname und Behring der Nachname B-E-H-R-I-N-G.
B-E-H-N-R-I-N-G.
R-I-N-G.
Behring.
Das ist eine Behring-Kanale.
Ja genau.
Friedhelm.
Wie kann ich Sie ansprechen?
Herr Behring, ja?
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Behring?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
56 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 4. Februar 1970.
1970.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
73 Kilo.
Haben Sie ungewollte Abodos genommen?
Ja, im letzten Jahr habe ich 8 Kilo abgenommen.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 Meter.
Ok, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ja, ich habe starke Bauchschmerzen.
Sehr starke Bauchschmerzen.
Seit ungefähr 10 Stunden.
Und am Anfang war ich sehr traurig.
Ich habe die Bauchschmerzen im Oberbauch.
Und jetzt sind sie im gesamten Bauch.
Und gehen auch in den Rücken.
Und in die linke Schulter.
Im gesamten Bauch.
Und übertragen die linke Schulter.
Ja, in den Rücken und linke Schulter.
Sind die Beschwerden erstmals aufgetreten?
Und plötzlich aufgetreten?
Also plötzlich sind die nicht aufgetreten.
Das hat so ein, zwei Stunden gedauert.
Dann waren die ziemlich stark, die Schmerzen.
Ich hatte solche Schmerzen, ähnliche Schmerzen.
Aber nicht so starke Schmerzen in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Schonmal, insgesamt glaube ich 3 Mal.
Aber die waren nie ganz so stark wie jetzt.
Wie letztes Jahr die Schmerzen hat selbst verschwunden?
Ja, das hat so zwei, drei Tage gedauert.
Und dann war das wieder weg.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Wie war die Schmerzen?
Eine stechende, bohrende oder brennende?
Das ist mehr ein dumpfer Schmerz.
Sie haben schon gesagt, die Ausstrahlung.
Könnten Sie nochmal sagen, dass die Schmerzen immer auf?
Die Schmerzen gehen einmal in den Rücken.
Der Schmerz in den Rücken und in die linke Schulter.
Aber Hauptquelle war der Oberbauch, ja?
Ja, aber jetzt tut der ganze Bauch weh.
Anfangs im Oberbauch.
Anfangs.
Wann ist das erste Mal, seit wann die Schmerzen unerträglich sind?
Seit 10 Stunden habe ich die Schmerzen.
Sie haben langsam angefangen, aber dann wurden sie sehr schnell stark.
Wie stark ist die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzenskala?
Wobei von 1 bis 10, 10 ist unerträglich?
7 bis 8.
Anfangs, wie war das?
Anfangs war es 5.
5, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Sie haben Schmerzen im ganzen Bauch, ja?
Inzwischen, ja.
Inzwischen ganz im Bauch, ja.
Leiden Sie Herzrasen auch?
Herzrasen habe ich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie Erbrachen oder Überkeit?
Mir ist übel und ich habe viermal Erbrachen.
Wie sieht die Erbrachung aus?
Schleimig, gelblich.
Zweimal Erbrachen, ja?
Viermal.
Entschuldigung.
Viermal Erbrachen, schleimig und gelblich.
Ja.
Gibt es eine Auslösung?
Gibt es etwas, das das Beschwerden verschlektet oder verhindert?
Also einen Auslöser kenne ich nicht.
Bewegung, wenn ich rum gehe, bewegen ist schlecht.
Ich muss mich am besten hinlegen.
Auf den Rücken.
Auslöser, keine.
Wenn Sie liegen, ist es ein bisschen schlendert, ja?
Ja, aber nicht viel.
Es ist besser, schlechter ist es, wenn ich stehe und gehe.
Das ist dann schlechter.
Sie haben ein bisschen Erschütterung Schmerzen, ja?
Ungefähr?
Ja, das kann sein, ja.
Kann sein, kann sein, okay.
Wie ist Ihre Essgewöhnlichkeit?
Haben Sie ein fettiges Essen?
Nein, fettiges Essen mag ich in letzter Zeit nicht so gerne.
Auch Obst mag ich nicht so gerne.
Ich esse Brot und sowas.
Aber jetzt, seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, habe ich auch keinen Appetit.
Habe ich nichts gegessen.
Seit wann haben Sie keinen Appetit?
Seit 10 Stunden.
Kein Appetit.
Normalerweise haben Sie eine Abneigung, die Essenabneigung?
Ich habe früher mehr Fleisch gegessen.
Das mag ich nicht mehr so gerne.
Fleisch gegessen.
Sind Sie febriker?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ist die Schmerzen eine Gültel vor mir?
Könnten Sie so sagen, Gültel vor mir?
Es strahlt so rücken.
Ich würde mal sagen, es strahlt mehr so links in den Rücken.
Mehr links, so ganz gürtelförmig nicht.
Ganz Gültel nicht, aber eher die links gestrahlt, ja?
Okay.
Haben Sie Verstopfungen oder Durchfall?
Nein.
Normalerweise habe ich jeden Tag Stuhlgang.
Den letzten Stuhlgang hatte ich gestern Morgen.
Aber ich habe auch wenig gegessen oder gar nichts gegessen.
Aber mit Stuhlgang habe ich normalerweise keine Probleme.
Ist Ihnen Hautfarbeänderung aufgefallen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Hautausschlag?
Habe ich nicht beobachtet.
Ist Ihnen Ürenfarbeänderung bemerkt?
Nein.
Üren?
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Nein.
Keine.
Sind bei Ihnen Vorerkrankungen und OP bekannt?
Ja, ich habe hohen Blutdruck.
Seit ungefähr fünf Jahren nehme ich da auch Tabletten ein.
Welche Tablette nehmen Sie dagegen?
Eine Mittel heißt Ramipril.
Ramipril, genau.
Wie viele Dosierung, wie viele Mal nehmen Sie?
Dahinter steht fünf.
Ich nehme davon eine Tablette am Morgen und eine abends.
Eine abends.
Dann nehme ich noch Purozimid.
Dahinter steht 20.
Dann nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Dann nehme ich noch eine Tablette gegen das hohe Cholesterin.
Seit ungefähr fünf Jahren.
Das Medikament heißt Rosuvastatin.
Rosuvastatin.
So was ich mir die gehe.
Da steht 20 hinter.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette abends.
Abends.
Vor einem Jahr hatte ich starke Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Da wurde bei mir ein Herzkatheter gemacht.
Bei dieser Katheteruntersuchung wurde eine Stelle am Herzen,
der Arzt hat gesagt, mit Kälte behandelt.
Mit Kälte.
Danach hatte ich wieder einen richtigen Herzrhythmus.
Da war der Herzrhythmus wieder in Ordnung.
Wie haben Sie behandelt?
Ich konnte nicht verstanden.
Das war eine Angehörige.
Herzkatheter gehabt.
Mit dem Katheter wurde eine Stelle am Herzen mit Kälte behandelt.
Kälte.
Kälte behandelt.
Danach war das Herz wieder im richtigen Rhythmus.
Das war Elektrophysiologie.
Ich weiß nicht was da gemacht wurde.
Also mit Kälte.
Mit Kälte.
Okay.
Erinnern Sie eine Quelle?
Ich erinnere mich nicht an das Wort.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind.
Da war ich 10 Jahre alt.
Da wurde ich am Leistenbruch operiert.
Auf der rechten Seite.
Leistenbruch.
Rechte Seite, ja?
Ja.
Vor 8 Jahren hatte ich einen Arbeitsunfall.
Da habe ich mir einen Handwurzelknochen gebrochen.
Das Kahnbein.
Handwurzel.
Knochen.
Wurden Sie operiert oder?
Erst nicht.
Das Kahnbein ist nicht zusammengeheilt richtig.
Danach musste ich operiert werden.
Ja.
Okay.
Wurden Sie auch Disziplin?
Atemnot habe ich nicht.
Wurden Sie Husten?
Ja, ich habe Husten.
Man sagt zu mir das ist Raucherhusten.
Raucherhusten.
Morgens, ja Sie meinen das.
Ja, morgens muss ich schon vermehrt Husten und auch Schleim abhusten.
Schleim.
Aber im Laufe des Tages wird das dann besser.
Also aber Sie haben keine Änderungen, Hautfarbeänderungen bemerkt.
Sind Sie blass?
Ich glaube nicht.
Danke.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche.
Ich rauche jeden Tag eine Schachtel Zigaretten.
Und das schon seit 35 Jahren.
Seit 35 Jahren.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol so sich?
Ja, ich trinke abends zwei Flaschen Bier im Schnitt.
Und auch zwei Flaschen Bier und auch manchmal einen Schnaps.
Zwei Flaschen Bier und einen Schnaps.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen ein vergrößter Bauch aufgefallen oder auf Blechung?
Nein.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen auch geschwollene Beine aufgefallen?
Nein, geschwollene Beine habe ich nicht.
Nein.
Haben Sie eine Schluckstörung?
Schluckstörung gegen Feste oder?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Mir ist noch eingefallen, Sie haben gesagt, chronische Erkrankung.
Ich hatte früher mehrfach 12-Finger-Darm-Geschwüre.
Und das wurde dann mit Tabletten behandelt.
Und vor drei Jahren hatte ich die letzte Spiegelung, Magenspiegelung.
Und da waren die Geschwüre aber nicht mehr da.
Und die Tabletten habe ich jetzt in letzter Zeit auch nicht mehr genommen.
Okay, das war vor drei Jahren, ja?
Zuletzt. Aber Geschwüre hatte ich schon früher, vor sieben oder acht Jahren.
Geschwüre war im Magen oder nur 12-Finger-Darm?
12-Finger-Darm.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Nüchtermagen verschleckert oder nach dem Essen Beschwerden verschleckert?
Ich habe zurzeit ja keine Schmerzen mehr am Magen oder am 12-Finger-Darm.
Das habe ich nicht.
Jetzt habe ich ja so ganz akute, starke Schmerzen seit gestern.
Das, glaube ich, hängt mit dem Magen nicht zusammen.
Glaube ich nicht.
Sie denken so, okay.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routine-Frage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Sie trinken jeden Tag zwei Flaschen Bier?
Ja, Alkohol trinke ich.
Aber ich verstehe unter Drogen so etwas wie, wie heißt das, Marihuana oder Cannabis oder so was.
Das nehme ich alles nicht.
Aber Sie nehmen regelmäßig zwei Flaschen Bier jeden Tag und zwei Schnaps?
Ja, ungefähr.
Sie mögen Alkohol?
Ja.
Ja, ich bin, ja.
Ja, genau.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie Vorerkrankungen?
Mein Vater ist mit 60 Jahren verstorben an Magenkrebs.
Magenkrebs, 60 Jahre, ja?
60 Jahre, ja.
Magenkrebs.
Mutter?
Die Mutter lebt noch.
Die Mutter ist 80 Jahre alt, wird 81.
Sie hat Alterszucker.
Und sie hatte vor gut zehn Jahren eine Gallenblasenentfernung wegen Gallenblasensteine.
Mein herzlichen Beleid für so einen Ehrevater.
Es tut mir leid.
Haben Sie auch Geschwister?
Eine Schwester habe ich, die ist 55 Jahre alt.
Entschuldigung, 52 Jahre alt.
Die hatte letztes Jahr Brustkrebs und wurde operiert und wurde mit Chemotherapie behandelt.
Aber ich glaube, es geht ja ganz gut.
Können Sie nochmal wiederholen, wie alt war diese Schwester?
52.
Und vor einem Jahr wurde Brustkrebs operiert bei ihr?
Vor einem Jahr Brustkrebs.
Musste operiert werden.
Vor einem Jahr.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Geschieden.
Ja, es tut mir leid.
Haben Sie ein Kind?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder.
Zwei Töchter.
Die sind 26 und 28 Jahre alt.
Die leben aber nicht mehr in der Stadt.
Die sind zu weit, ich weiß, gesund.
Die sind gesund, ja?
Sie wohnen alleine oder...
Ja, ich wohne alleine.
Was machen Sie von beruflich?
Ich bin im Straßenbau tätig.
Straßenbau tätig.
Eine Mauer oder was war das?
Nein, Asphalt.
Wir bauen Straßen, Rücken, Kreuzungen, Autobahnen.
Ja, genau.
Es ist eine schwere Arbeit.
Ja, bei Wind und Wetter.
Und ja, ich bin auch in der Stadt.
Ich habe auch ein kleines Haus.
Ja, bei Wind und Wetter.
Und ja, es ist eine schwere Arbeit.
Ja, genau. Ich verstehe Ihnen.
Es ist eine schwere Arbeit.
Waren Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten im Ausland?
Nein.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich glaube ja.
Da achtet meine Hausärztin drauf und der Betriebsarzt.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein. Ich habe mal früher Fußball gespielt, aber das ist schon lange her.
Am Anfang, Sie haben gesagt, dass im letzten sechs, letzten Jahr acht Kilo abgenommen.
Das war ungewohnt, ja?
Sie haben keine besondere Diät gemacht.
Nein, Diät habe ich nicht gemacht.
Aber irgendwie hat sich mein Appetit verändert.
Ich habe ja gesagt, ich esse weniger Fleisch.
Früher auch mehr Obst gegessen.
Aber wann hat Ihr Appetit reduziert?
Ungefähr seit einem Jahr.
Im letzten Jahr habe ich ungefähr acht Kilo Gewicht abgenommen.
Aber Sie haben keine besondere Abneigung?
Nein, keine Diät gemacht, keine Abneigung direkt.
Fleisch esse ich nicht mehr so gerne.
Nach dem Fleischessen verursacht Nausea oder irgendwas.
Was ist Nausea?
Übelkeit.
Naja, ich esse gar nicht mehr so viel Fleisch.
Also wie gesagt, früher habe ich sehr viel Fleisch gegessen.
Jeden Tag. Jetzt vielleicht nur noch einmal die Woche.
Vielen Dank.
Mir ist noch etwas eingefallen.
Seit ungefähr einem Jahr habe ich häufig in den Beinen, besonders in den Unterschenkeln, Taubbein gesessen.
Und so kribbeln wie Ameisen laufen auf der Haut.
Das ist sehr unangenehm.
Besonders nachts sind die Beine dann sehr unruhig, ich kann dann nicht so gut schlafen.
Das ist seit einem Jahr.
Seit einem Jahr? Sie haben Taubsalpgefühle.
Und so kribbeln auf der Haut wie eine Ameise, wenn sie über die Haut läuft.
Ist Ihnen ein Säcken oder Insekten bis auf die Haut gelaufen?
Nein.
Ok.
Hatten Sie früher eine Verletzung oder Unfall gehabt?
Ich meine Rückenverletzung.
Nein, kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Aber die Taubheitsgefühle nur die links.
Nein, in beiden Unterschenkeln.
Beiden?
Aber Sie haben keine Lähmung oder?
Nein.
Lähmung habe ich nicht.
Es ist so ein Kribbeln und manchmal brennt die Haut etwas.
Und unangenehm.
Wie verstärkt ist das Kribbeln-Gefühl meist nachts oder tagsüber?
Ich spüre das nachts mehr.
Weil in der Nacht spüre ich das stärker.
Dann ist es manchmal schwierig mit dem Schlafen.
Wegen des diese nachts unruhige Füßchen stört es sich Schlafen.
Ja.
Ok.
Interessant.
Normalerweise kennen Sie Restless Legs-Syndrom.
Ist Ihnen bei Ihnen ein Restless Legs-Syndrom festgestellt?
Bisher wurde das nicht so.
Das habe ich meinem Hausarzt noch gar nicht gesagt.
Mit den Beinen.
Ok.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit.
Meinerseits habe ich wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Mir fehlt jetzt nichts mehr ein.
Zusätzlich.
Genau.
Dann haben Sie jetzt einige Minuten Zeit die Dinge vorzubereiten.
Vielleicht am Kollegen noch Ergänzungsfragen.
Wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann lasse ich Sie jetzt mal einige Minuten in Ruhe.
Dass Sie sich konzentrieren können.
Ich würde ehrlich sagen, ich konnte nicht entscheiden, was war der Grund hauptsatzlicher, was war der Grund für die Aufmerksamkeit.
Ich bin zwischen den Fragen.
Es geht jetzt noch nicht um die richtige Diagnose.
Versuchen Sie jetzt erst mal die Schilderung des Patienten zu übersetzen in Fachsprache.
Und dann kommen wir vielleicht der Diagnose etwas näher.
Danke schön.
Die medizinischen Fachausdrücke sind jetzt wichtiger als eine richtige Diagnose.
Okay, bis gleich.
Danke.
So, wie sieht es aus?
Können wir es versuchen?
Mal sehen.
Ich versuche.
Ob ich es schaffe oder nicht.
Mal sehen.
Haben Sie Kurse seit?
Ja, habe ich.
Liebe Oberarzt, ich würde gerne einen Patienten vorstellen.
Herfried Berling ist 56 Jahre alt, geboren am 4. Februar, im Jahr 2016.
Er wiegt aktuell 73 kg und 1,84 m groß.
Er stellt sich seit sechs Stunden bestehende,
Oberbauchschmerzen vor.
Anfangs schmerzen bestimmte Oberbauchschmerzen.
Und im Moment schmerzen sich die Oberbauchschmerzen.
Schmerzen würden die linke Schulter und die linke Rücken ausstrahlen.
Okay, ich unterhalte das.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wie sieht es aus?
Wo sieht es aus?
Auf der linken Schulter und der linken rücken ausstrahlen.
Ich unterbrech eine kurz, danke.
dass er seit 10 Stunden starke Abdominalschmerzen hat, die anfangs im Epigastrium waren, inzwischen
aber im gesamten Abdomen, mit Ausstrahlung nach Dorsal und in die linke Skapula.
Schulterregion Skapula und in den Rücken möglichst nach Dorsal.
Dorsum der Rücken. Fahren Sie bitte fort.
Genau. Ja, ähnliche Beschwerden hatte er vor, hatte er letztes Jahr und die Beschwerden
selbst, die Beschwerden hat selbst ausgelöst.
Ja, also richtig war, der Patient hat gesagt, ähnliche Beschwerden hatte ich innerhalb der
letzten drei Jahre oder zwei Jahre schon dreimal.
Ja, dreimal.
Heute ist es das vierte Mal, dass er solche Beschwerden hat.
Genau, vierte Mal. Ja, falsch.
Schmerzintensität ist Anfangs bei fünf von zehn, aktuelle acht von zehn.
Er hat Nausea und vier Mal Emesis gehabt.
Erbrochen ist gelblich und schleimig.
Die Auffrage nach Auslösung wurde verneint.
Können Sie etwas zum Charakter des Schmerzes sagen?
Charakter, ja, Charakter war Dumpfenschmerzen.
Dumpferschmerzen.
Ja, Dumpfenschmerzen. Charakter war Dumpfenschmerzen. Entschuldigung, ich habe vergessen das zu sagen.
Ich habe Appetitlosigkeit.
Inappetenz.
Ich habe acht Kilo Gewichtverlust innerhalb eines Jahres.
Eines Jahres, ja, okay.
Eines Jahres, in der Arme eines Jahres.
Die Frage nach Temperatur, Diarrhea, Obstupation, Exanthem, Ürineinwanderung wurden verneint.
Aufgrund einer Rauche hat er gestern morgens mit Auswurf, aber das war ganz in der Zeit.
Ja, genau.
Er berichtet, laut Patientenangabe hat er Taubheitsgefühle an beiden Unterschenkeln.
An beiden Unterschenkeln, ja. Taubheitsgefühle oder man kann eventuell sagen, es kribbelt so.
Sagen Sie ruhig Kribbelparastesin. Kribbelparastesin.
Kribbelparastesin oder Parastesin an beiden Unterschenkeln.
Wie lange schon?
Wie lange?
Wie lange, ich kann nicht erinnern, aber die Taubheitsgefühle tritt vor allem nachts auf.
Ja, seit einem Jahr hat er das.
Seit einem Jahr.
Normalerweise können wir sagen, eine Restless-Legs-Syndrom benutzung die...
Vielleicht. Wir haben es noch nicht diagnostiziert. Der Patient kennt das nicht, den Begriff.
Der Patient hat nur gesagt, ich habe seit einem Jahr so Kribbelgefühl in den Beinen und Taubheitsgefühl.
Und das ist nachts verstärkt, aber tagsüber habe ich das auch.
Das ist jetzt erst mal nur eine anamnestische Angabe.
Sie müssen das dann später noch weiter diagnostizieren wahrscheinlich.
Aber eine wichtige Angabe ist das.
Genau, eine wichtige Angabe.
Wenn der Patient raucht, können Sie mir was sagen über seinen Nikotin-Ponsum?
Ja, das würde ich gerne als Vorerkrankungen erzählen.
Okay, okay.
Oder ich kann auch...
Als Vorerkrankungen gab es folgende Artillerle-Hypertonie.
Er nimmt aber noch ein Mittel gegen die Hypertonie.
Er leidet Rhythmusstörungen.
Er riecht nach Katheter.
Er riecht nach Katheter-Ablasionen.
Ich denke mal, das war eine ektopische Ecknü.
Rhythmusstörung-Quelle.
Er hatte eine Katheter-Ablation mit Croio-Therapie.
Also eine Croio-Ablation.
Croio-Ablation, ja.
Und diese Croio-Ablation war dir erfolgreich?
Ja, erfolgreich.
Vor zehn Jahren.
Ne, vor einem Jahr.
Entschuldigung.
Und wegen eines Unfalls musste er vor acht Jahren operiert werden.
Warum?
Flanken.
Normalerweise eine Flanken.
Nein, das waren keine Flanken.
Eine Handwurzelknochenfraktur.
Und zwar das Kahnbein.
Kahnbein ist K-A wie unten das steht in Chat.
Kahnbeinfraktur, das ist das Oskafoidium.
Skafoid.
S-C-A-B-H-Skafoid.
Das ist das Kahnbein.
Können wir sagen, das war eine ...
Kapal würde ich nicht sagen.
Nee, Kapal würde ich nicht sagen.
Sagen Sie ruhig eine Handwurzelknochenfraktur.
Und zwar in diesem Falle das Oskafoidium.
Also das Kahnbein.
Kahnbein, genau.
Und das musste operiert werden, weil es konservativ nicht gut war.
Aber der Patient hatte noch eine Operation.
Noch eine Operation?
Als Kind?
Als Kind, genau.
Als Kind ...
Wo habe ich geschrieben?
Ah, Leistenburg, Hernian.
Genau, genau.
Rechten Hernian.
Inguinal Hernian.
Inguinal Hernian, sehr gut.
Vor zehn Jahren wurde der Patient rechtzeitig an einer Inguinal Hernia operiert.
So kann man das sagen.
Gut.
Es besteht eine Rauchanalyse von 35 Packungen im Jahr.
Wir nehmen regelmäßig zwei Flaschen Bier und zwei Schnapschen täglich.
Die Drogenkonsumiere wurden verneint.
Keine Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten.
Er ist geschieden.
Er hat zwei Kinder.
Die sind gesund.
Er wohnt alleine.
Was noch?
Der Schwester hat eine Leidenschaft an Mama Carcinoma vor einem Jahr festgestellt.
Mit zwei und fünf Jahren alt.
Und der Vater?
Der Vater ist leider gestorben.
Was habe ich geschrieben?
Ich kann nicht lesen.
Der Vater ist gestorben.
60 Jahre alt.
An einen Magenkrebs.
Wie würden Sie das im medizinischen Fach sagen?
Gastrikarcinom.
Oder Magenkarzinom geht auch.
Aber möglichst nicht Magenkrebs.
Magenkarzinom.
Der Vater ist verstorben.
Und die Mutter?
Die Mutter leidet an Diabetes Typ 2.
Das habe ich geschrieben, aber ich habe vergessen.
Das war etwas noch.
Vor zehn Jahren.
Die Mutter ist glaube ich 82 Jahre alt.
80 Jahre alt.
Und die hatte noch eine Operation vor einigen Jahren.
Die Mutter?
Mutter?
Ja.
Ah, Polycystekdomin.
Polycystekdomin.
Okay.
Gut.
Was ist der Patient von Beruf?
Der Patient ist im Straßenbau tätig.
Im Straßenbau, okay.
Ja, jetzt haben wir einige Gedanken.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Aufgrund der anämistischen Angabe und geschilderten Beschwerden
habe ich Verdacht an akuten Abdomen.
Am ehesten akuten Abdomen, akut Pankreatitis.
Aber gastrik Perforation habe ich auch Verdacht.
Magenperforation.
Aber am ehesten würde ich sagen akut Pankreatitis.
Okay.
Gut.
Wie würden Sie denn die Schmerzereignisse der letzten drei Jahre werden?
Also sie hat ja innerhalb der letzten drei Jahre
dreimal so relativ starke Bauchschmerzen gehabt.
Genau.
Was kann das gewesen sein?
Ja, Polycystitis oder Polycystiasis kann sein auch, oder?
Kann es nicht auch eine Pankreatitis gewesen sein?
Ja, aber natürlich.
Am ehesten würde ich sagen akut Pankreatitis.
Aber es ist weiter...
Ich glaube oder es kann sein, dass der Patient jetzt
einen akuten Schub einer chronischen Pankreatitis hat.
Also ich glaube, inzwischen ist die Pankreatitis chronisch.
Wir wissen noch gar nicht über seine Zuckerwerte,
wie die waren in letzter Zeit.
Aber er hat eine Neuropathie entwickelt.
Das hängt wahrscheinlich mit dem Alkoholkonsum zusammen.
Mit dem langjährigen Alkoholkonsum.
Die Beschwerden wie eine Neuropathie,
eine beginnende oder sich ausbreitende Polyneuropathie.
Die Beschwerden nach Dorsal einstrahlen,
in die linke Schulter, spricht für Pankreas.
Und nicht für Galle.
Galle ist mehr rechtsorientiert.
Ich würde fast eher sagen, der Patient hat eine Pankreatitis.
Der dumpfe Schmerz, sehr starke Schmerz.
VRS8 finde ich ist schon sehr stark.
Der Pankritin-Anamnese spricht dafür.
Eventuell hat er irgendwas in ein Ulcus ventriculi oder Ulcus duodeni.
Was eventuell gedeckt perforiert ist.
Was auch immer. Wir wissen es nicht genau.
Er hat sicherlich ein akutes Abdomen.
Aber das ist nur der Oberbegriff.
Die Eingrenzung Richtung Pankreas.
In die Richtung muss man denken.
Es spricht auch diese kontinuierliche Gewichtsabnahme
innerhalb eines Jahres für eine Pankreatitis.
Das haben wir häufig.
Die Patienten haben geänderte Appetitverhalten.
Sie meiden bestimmte Nahrungsmittel,
weil sie sie nicht mehr gut vertragen.
Im Chat stand auch Pankreascarcinom.
Auch das kann sein.
Aber ein Pankreascarcinom
macht in der Regel keinen heften, akuten Schmerz.
Oft ist es lange stumm.
Das ist die Gefahr beim Pankreascarcinom.
Dass es lange unentdeckt bleibt.
Aber es geht nicht darum, wer Recht hat.
Wichtig ist, dass Sie viele richtige Fachbegriffe benutzen.
Das tun Sie.
Manchmal habe ich den Eindruck,
Ihre Aufzeichnungen sind etwas,
aber die Begriffe haben Sie wieder zu finden.
Da haben Sie in der Prüfung mehr Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Aber die meisten Begriffe können Sie.
Die haben Sie parat.
Sie können Sie erinnern.
Das ist wichtig.
Wichtig ist, dass Sie den Patienten am Ende Gelegenheit geben,
dass der Patient vielleicht noch etwas ergänzen kann.
Oder wenn er etwas nicht verstanden hat.
Manchmal fallen den Patienten wichtige Daten ein.
Dann sagt der Patient plötzlich,
ich habe seit einem Jahr ein Torpeitsgefühl in den Beinen.
Das kann durchaus eine sinnvolle Begleitdiagnose sein.
Bei diesem Krankheitsbild.
Oder manchen fällt vielleicht plötzlich ein.
Sie haben gleich die Frage nach dem Gewicht gestellt.
Gleich zu Anfang.
Das wird leider manchmal vergessen.
Vielleicht der Patient sagt,
seit einem Jahr habe ich 8 kg Gewicht verloren.
Das ist dann schon eine wichtige Angabe.
Aber das haben Sie von Anfang an gestellt.
Vielen Dank.
Sie haben die Hyperlipidämie absichtlich gegeben.
Das war eine...
Eigentlich heißt es Hyperkolesterynämie.
Ich habe Hyperlipidämie gelten lassen.
In diesem Sinne Hyperkolesterynämie.
Da stehen wir auch Triklyzeride drunter.
Im Blut.
In diesem Fall war es nur das Cholesterin.
Cholesterin ist dafür wie Pankreatitis.
Hyperlipidämie ist der Oberbegriff.
Aber das sind die Sachen, die der Patient einnimmt.
Ich glaube, der Patient ist nicht so oft beim Arbeiten.
Das ist ein Problem.
Er ist nicht so oft beim Arzt.
Er hat nicht so eine Super-Compliance.
Das glaube ich einfach mal.
Er hat viele Risikofaktoren.
Er hat eine positive Familienanamnese durch den Vater.
Er trinkt zu viel Alkohol.
Er hat einen für meine Begriffe Nicotine ab Usus.
35 Jahre.
Jeden Tag eine Schachtel.
Er hat auch eine Schachtel an Noxen, Nicotine und Schadstoffen.
Er hat viele Risikofaktoren.
Die arteriöse Hypertonie.
Erst mal vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank.
Die Dauer der Anamnese war ein gutes Stück über 20 Minuten.
Dass Sie sich da eine Uhr hinlegen.
Dass Sie möglichst die 20 Minuten einhalten.
Das kann sonst sein, dass gesagt wird,
jetzt ist Anamnese zu Ende.
20 Minuten sind rum.
Dass Sie möglichst die Zeit nicht überschreiten.
Sie haben voll gekriegt.
Vielen Dank.
Jetzt noch mal die Bitte an die Gruppe.
Nächste Woche kann ich nicht, aber in 14 Tagen.
Da bin ich wieder für Sie da.
Nächste Woche sind Sie nicht da?
Ich würde Ihnen das bitte der Koordinatorin mitteilen.
Okay.
Ich werde Ihnen mitteilen.
Alles klar.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend.
Bis in 2 Wochen.